been fortunate off to be here the last
couple of years and just in an amazing
standard of movies and it was kind of
shocking to know that these had such
young people behind them but that's
what's fantastic about first line is
that it recognizes those people and of
course there's a lot of support and you
know without first light it may not
necessarily happen and and and teachers
lend a helping hand but ultimately it's
it's all fed through these cars
imagination and their creativity and you
know as young people I think there's so
much of it and it's such an incredible
resource and it's something that should
not only be kind of you know cultivated
but celebrated that's what events like
this are about Nick tell me a little bit
about your inspiration for getting
involved in the film walk if you've been
in the movie industry for a little while
made a lot of good films Wow I've got no
opinion I've been involved about 30
years but before that I was in rock and
roll and that was just as fun but well
because film is is all storytelling
which of course rock and roll is is is
not so much and I've saw that people
were making films like Billy Wilder till
there were 90 and I was you know getting
worried so I figured that that would be
a good career to go to I knew there
wouldn't be any pensions left by the
time I got old that I'd need to be
working till I drop but the best thing
about films is it's a whole emotion
comedy story acting all those different
things come together and as its jack'd a
total joy and then I go and waste it
watching films like bridge over river
kwai and things like that she doesn't
have any jokes in it now will your
inspiration was to get involved in
acting because a big breakthrough may be
this sort of Rambo wasn't it well I was
gonna make a serious joke in that my
genuine problem at school was that I
wasn't good at anything but I had an
incredible drama teacher who sort of
instilled a lot of you know confidence
in me through her belief and her passion
for drama and I was very lucky in that I
you know I wish I would have had
something like first light to be
involved in
so I'm just all the more thankful that I
had that drama teacher believed in me
but I think for people who don't have
that you know organizations foundations
like first light really do create the
most wonderful opportunity that you have
to take advantage of and you have to
snatch you know and you know these guys
they've made their you know first
animation but I really really really
hope going on to make more because it's
so inspiring to see young people
genuinely you know grow from from sort
of root level and take it all the way
into the professional industry and these
guys are well on their way sure they'll
all be inspired by seeing your example
as well both yours you know in the movie
industry little voice all those
brilliant films that you've made over
the years and will as well the movies
that you hopefully seeing from you in
the very near future like the Maze
Runner I hear might be one of them yeah
yeah no I'm saying that in May so
looking forward to it yeah and of course
that could be with it being a book and a
being a trilogy it could be one of these
massive massive kind of films like the
Twilight series or those kind of things
we've seen how do you feel about being
in something like that how would it
change your life do you think I don't
know I'm not sure I'm ready for that
actually but yeah right the bill that
you've scared me advice would you give
to guys like these who would hopefully
be getting to that stage at some point
if they want to get keep involved in the
film a certain industry in the future I
mean I think we just said just to keep
going keep practicing practice makes
perfect and to just gain as much
experience as you can heap up every
opportunity in sight and and really just
you know build up your your confidence
through experience is the best thing to
do keep making movies keeping involved
well as well so the combination of film
Club and first light which didn't exist
in my era or one not a lot existed in my
er actually but in terms of the
entertainment business but is yeah keep
doing it keep watching it keeps seeing
your heroes keep learning from all the
people around you and and and the people
who do it great and there's so much less
a gap between the work that we've seen
here and the professional work of the
world it's getting narrower and narrower
all the time and they're all going to be
Mozart soon
you